a spitting image puppet of Margaret
Thatcher has been put up for auction was
a show which was a huge hit in the 90s
so what's happening to political satire
now in 2019 join me to discuss that of a
comedian and impressionist Jon Culshaw
who as well now one of the stars of
radio force Dead Ringers and from
Charlie wood we're joined by Tim North
the general manager of the prop saw
which is auctioning the mrs. Thatcher
puppet and mr. laws got the puppet there
I think you've actually got 40 splitting
images or something like that show us it
a bit
that's correct we've got full yeah we've
got 41 spitting image of puppets going
out for auction on the 14th of February
props all calm and we're very excited
about it what sort of price do you think
they're gonna raise bidding start from a
hundred pounds on most of the Lots for
the exception of the right honourable
lady here he's going to start at two
thousand pounds and I mean there's a bit
of a market in these puppets already
what's the top prices they've hit so far
they have gone as much as ten thousand
pounds in the past in the long distant
past so we're very interested to see how
well these will fare in the market is it
a bit spooky being standing there next
to a caricature of Margaret Thatcher
it's a little bit odd but I think she's
looking good I think she's looking as
good as she did back in the day so is
it's not scary as it could be though is
that looking over her shoulder I don't
remember him from splitting the image oh
he's from but he's from Highlander
that's a whole whole different whole
different thing
and where's the where's the auction
auction bidding starts out on
Valentine's Day on the 14th
of February at prop store calm bidding
is open for two weeks and bidding starts
to close on the 27th of February ok mr.
Lewis thank you very much indeed
Charley bring happy memories doesn't it
it certainly does it certainly doesn't
the the sort of the violence of the
caricatures of spitting image there was
wonderful grotesque Church gargoyles
were a comment on the characters before
a word of the script had even been
written because that mean [ __ ] noisy
started I mean they started out as
caricaturist him though at least to make
these models for the Sunday Times and
other newspapers he was very interesting
hearing Steve Newlin's wonderful
Margaret Thatcher voice there his great
great skill in how he judged that you
know you couldn't have a simple normal
Margaret Thatcher that's that sort of
good calm tone it had to be really over
the top to match the caricatures of the
puppets and he judged that so so
beautifully do you think your show would
be there if it wasn't for spitting image
now well I think this this talk of
spitting image coming back and certainly
on dead ringers on radio for you do feel
the sense with the political climate now
that the audience does turn to the show
to crystallize the stories just to make
some sense of it and also throw some
Rotten Tomatoes at the same time I mean
the sense is even more difficult for you
on the radio because you don't have the
visual images so the voices have got
really cut through to the public yes
exactly and it all it also allows for
that certain kind of writing that you
get on radio very incisive theater of
the mind it allows you to have a certain
tone of comedy which lends well with
dead ringers across between private eye
and the Beano almost its very image I
think I'm right saying was it was one of
those kind of diaspora shows where an
enormous number of talents who went on
to do things came together yes you look
at the writers in his lop for example
and the voice artists Harry Enfield
Steve Coogan many people have passed
through the the corridors of spitting
image on their way to the did you work
there at all I did it what a spitting
image was my first job on television
just after the Thatcher era yes the John
Major time was when I joined and will
say you know Tony Blair you know you
could see the puppet
is working the Tony Blair puppet had to
work very hard indeed almost like c-3po
and I do worry or assign characters was
that hurt worked
yes exactly the the topical stories
would be done on the on the Friday but
will always be the same person doing
Blair or the yeah once you've once
you've got your character you you tend
to stay with it so who were yours on
splitting image I did let me see Kenneth
Clark Chris Eubank victor Meldrew Frank
Bruno Michael Portillo he was one of
mine in his defense secretary days
before great railway journeys so it was
a wonderful place to start is there a
bit sort of Sunset Boulevard about it
you know Norma Desmond saying the
pictures have got small I mean have the
people you caricature got small compared
to the fetchers there was a time
certainly the David Cameron and you know
nick clegg era was a little bit like
that but then in came Boris Boris was
the quantitative easing amongst bland
impersonation characters and then Faraj
and now Corbin and Trump my goodness
gracious you know you can now get more
caricature than that so of course you
got a character like trouble indeed
Boris and you can't make it up how could
you satirized altro it's very good for
the writers because they go much more
specific they go on his bluff though the
things he tries to cover up when he gets
caught out from his ignorance and
there's something very satisfying about
that that the jab is even stronger
somehow what they've got to say we
talked about the beginning what they've
got at spitting images are these really
beautiful puppets and a lot of shows
around the world in America and France
Germany I know copied it but none of
them had anything as beautiful as these
pata exactly the the caricatures on
other shows were too tame
it almost looked like a you know you
could think of it like a Kids program
almost the I once saw it was Gerald
Scarfe I once watched him doing a just a
sketch
caricature of Margaret Thatcher and the
motion squad this unit as if he was
conducting an orchestra too strict to
know what to stretch him to exaggerate
it so perfectly so do you think we're
the best at sutter here oh yes
absolutely that mix of being very
incisive and also very cynical and that
satisfying feeling of calling things out
and bursting bubbles yes I mean have you
tried to explain your programme to
foreigners I think now I think that sort
of attitude of British satire is much
more universal certainly in America
since Sir John Stewart for example that
attitude is permeating now I think there
is a global thirst for that cynical sort
of hard-hitting
and who's that who's the big challenge
who has nobody managed to get us yet I
think it was always David Cameron really
you know quite a nerd I'm quite blend
you know that sort of repeated hair
gesture wanted to get the interview ever
as quickly as possible then run away to
Tuscany or nice is described by Danny
Dyer yes exactly we're going to that did
and difficult to tell the difference
between him and George Osborne I suppose
yet George Osborne had a sort of a
understated sinister quality there's
something like that you could have a
Machiavellian underscore with him
whereas David Cameron was just sort of
you know keep the PR tidy and get out as
quick as possible
and we haven't had a spitting image of
Boris Johnson but I mean for he's he
that the satirist choice private well my
goodness gracious yes that would
certainly be a tumbling ball of
something or other
most of caricatures of Boris tend to
look like a sort of an Old English
Sheepdog yeah yeah just speaking in
Latin and not being generally aware of
things you couldn't you wouldn't a
little of Boris goes a long way in
satire terms not just in satire thank
you very much daddy Joe Joe Joe